I have to ask you this because this is
the craziest thing I've ever heard
literally and I've been doing this Four
Seasons is it true that your mom had you
live on Alcatraz a little bit when
you're a child like what's that story
yeah you know I was I was born and
raised in San Francisco yeah and briefly
in 1969 a a group of young Native
American students from San Francisco
State decided to take over Alcatraz
Island as kind of a political statement
as most of you know Alcatraz was a
federal penitentiary up until 1962. yeah
and it remained out of operation until
1969 and these young students were smart
enough to cite an old treaty from the
1800s that cited any government-held
land that was not being used reverts
back to the sovereignty of native people
so it was a political gesture
that was National News international
news for that matter and my mom was a
part of the group that then settled on
the island for during the 18-month
occupation I was five years old and I
lived in the city but I would say every
weekend at least two nights a week we
were living on the island that your mom
is so cool cool that's my that's my
brother Peter who's a filmmaker now and
my youngest sister veruszka I was
actually meant to be in that shot but I
got bored
on accident I was running around the
other part of the cell block yeah I've
been to Alcatraz that would be a scary
place kind of for a kid or but it wasn't
scary at all because you know
I think parents are different about the
responsibilities in raising kids these
days it wasn't my mom didn't care about
us she was like just go play and so we'd
go free yeah go under the industrial
side of the island and you know throw
rocks at windows and go crabbing you
know we'd go down on the shoreline and
and look for crabs Etc but uh it was the
ultimate playground really for me and my
brother and my three sisters yeah it's
just a really cool thing too to like
introduce
something that's important like and show
your kids to think outside of yourself
at such young ages that's cool yeah you
know this was in the aftermath of my mom
getting a divorce from my father and she
was an immigrant she came from from Lima
Peru at the age of 14. and so I think
she felt a little left untethered and so
when she found this native community and
it embraced her fully uh she found in a
way her her own sense of identity and
it's an identity a native identity that
she left us as a legacy you know she
actually called the Young Mohawk leader
Richard Oaks who was the leader of the
young student group that took over the
island and got him on the phone when he
was on the local KQED PBS channel and
she said I'm Native American from South
America does that count he said Indians
of all tribes come down and she said
it's the first time this that she was in
the country that she felt like she
belonged but what's unusual is this
habit we we have had historically of
trying to put everyone in a specific box
this is what you are and that's your
identity leave the identifying to the
individual it's something I continue to
hand down to my own children that's cool
you had a rad mama
and listen she's she's still doing the
do I mean my mother is she's the center
of the universe for all of us that's so
cool not everybody gets that kind of
family that's kind of magical and and
that's the American story I mean an
immigrant comes to to this country
has children and she ends up finding a
way to contribute
[Music]
[Applause]